so what'd you do I thought I wasn't
recording the sound therefore oh what
the arsonist kept crying as he was
slowly lowered on an off the impaler it
didn't take much to break him they had
meant for him to die but the torture was
working beyond their expectation wasn't
the method it was the arsonist he was
different from the others they could
make him forget again oh now I remember
that guy we're gonna kill these pieces
of the orb to torture people and we're
basically in the torture chamber now so
that's why we're finding different parts
I would assume there's a dead guy in
that one I don't think I saw him there
before that's creepy
oh don't tell me it's that it's got a
pig
no it's a man oh can you speak no he's
dead
and it's glad the monster isn't here
but I think I spoke too soon but where
is the monster he appears everywhere oh
I hear moaning over here and Saul's so
this is not good
did I just see the move my sanity is
that the lowest right now
why because scarier stuff is happening
[ __ ]
yeah dude can you see that hey that's
not nice and your own aah
Oh God okay we got an old piece so I got
two pieces now wow you know fire oh [ __ ]
what's going on here
the rig's like I hang upside down his
tears soiled with blood floating from
his belly he saw between his legs had a
lot itself in the hip and wouldn't move
any further the man sat back and waited
for the victim to drain ah seriously
ah but bro he was a rapist the Navy was
like a Caiaphas wait what
they took away children to this place as
well
I don't think anyone deserves that to be
honest
[ __ ] my sanity is so low right now
okay I think the lost pieces in here
so let's go in there
Oh
what's going on here now the torture
chamber
okay let's see what this is I can see
that oh oh they break her arms yeah yeah
it's nice I got a knife though
if we get up ya know I can just throw it
oh [ __ ]
tinderbox need that
first award the kidnapper sat on her
knees with her hands tied behind her
back she felt her hands being lifted and
her body followed her shoulders gave way
to the weight of her own body and
cracked loudly yeah he'll [ __ ] yeah
what's that noise
I'm guessing the last pieces in here
ah all right we got all the parts now I
think
oh I can hear that's oh alright
let's get the [ __ ] out of here I think I
gotta go up there at first
wow I don't want to go up there yeah
yeah don't you get all the whoops on
this level I think because he used them
for torture and this is the torture yes
oh I'm on ya for 3e I'm guessing the
last one is up here oh there is but
painting is not pleasant
sometimes it changes depending on what's
your sanity yeah it's horrible I think
this is nice
no nice environment yeah I guess it is
what is this a rope string and a note
there are quite a few things to be said
about torture I'd figured that the
reaction I would get from the victims
would be highly individual thanks
thankfully this is not kids humans all
have a very similar approach to dealing
with physical pain and the terror of
anticipation I can't stress enough the
importance of restraining the victims
before proceeding maybe the most timid
creature can break out in fits of
violence where their strength exceeds
their expected prowess if proper care
has been put into breaking the victim
this should not be a problem but it will
also hinder the effect I'm after god
damn it's so [ __ ] horrible the right
steps to take care take are there for to
restrain while the victim is still dazed
for proceed but [ __ ] why do I have to
read this as long the body suffers it
will continue to proceed by tale and
saturate the blood with this probably
wait something about amnesia
yeah I think I saw something yeah it
only with careful performance will the
victim yield maximum effect if the
victim doesn't behave as expected it is
likely that all will be for naught
before this happens feed them with
amnesia drink and try again later
Oh that's what we drank yeah a raised
memory yeah I think so I don't know I
hate this what's that is it you my love
I miss the most or is it perhaps myself
I know what I'm I have become I am NOT
blind I am a monster to them a demonic
Salton perch on a dark mountaintop
there's little I can do to redeem myself
the black ego fears me and after
Napoleon's defeat it is only a matter of
time before they will de mine my head
head on a platter I must remove myself
from this land this is this time it it
must work okay I'm pretty sure Alexander
wrote that
and I would guess that he's trying
mostly he looks very rich yeah yes I
mean he owns his castle okay so there
were nothing creepy up there so I'm glad
and I think now we can go back to the
workplace I don't know how to put the
orb together I'm guessing you're gonna
do it with it
tar oh now we're talking yeah you know
what you use tar for no for the pose oh
yeah leaking what that guy is very
strange
yes yes much like those from dead space
yeah I Canada you actually the orbits
near
the remaining pieces can be find in the
choir Oh
oh yeah it's in here as well [ __ ]
great I forgot about that this is just a
replace I have no idea what's in here
but I'm guessing it's bad news okay it's
the same as before
don't you say no you can't it does that
for you basically
so much they always see a great passion
Al's a year they'll want taunts me from
the other side reasoning with my true
some guy
I have to read this I guess where we
want to read it can pause it I'm sick of
reading
should I read if you want to from where
go ahead right up there where your
taunts with the other side I trusted him
with my true reason for my efforts he
still insisted me releasing Agrippa how
an enlightened man can show such lack of
compassion you see the power disgusts me
I can't bring myself to part from
Agrippa as his and it's been for
centuries mariner-link the worst fear
where you claim to Christ best relieve
him from my punishment
but that he needs me to give him a grip
of thirst so he do Cal if you could
guarantee success I would have to have
lied but how am I support from if my
return might be denied and know that
they are capable well it moves me wait
wait I know what they are capable of of
adding their deception
optimism is our most hopeless feeling
but I must retain it I should prepare
for his release to release Agrippa
without killing me we're told me to feed
him a tonic made from a paralyzer bit am
tempted the poisonous fund you should
work as paralyzer if I can find the
internal gland from a large basement
sure quiet be a fertile grounds for the
sword I should then be a bit extracting
contents with the proper tools the Vth
could be extracted as usual from an
agonized human victim's blood just need
large Mouse's seal it properly
remember to collect this during the next
took your torture session tempter on
data and will prove more difficult I
don't think it exists in this world
simply write in the word with these
letters looks wrong I place this
property of the secretion in the water
dwelling kind I will have to address
where witnesses will have to supply me
with a host also properly prepared well
she'd surface to contain it yeah that
was nicely done I don't get her where is
good name yeah but I was thinking it
would could be our name like our last
name or something cuz I've never heard
of it before
wasn't it a substance oh I have no idea
not more stuff to read but these aren't
really important okay you mean the notes
are important well if you want to
understand the story but these are just
like creepy [ __ ] then I don't like that
yeah it's a great but yeah it's change
yeah exactly
many and it's his orb were collecting
basically why is she talking about the
other world are the two words
I'm guessing yeah I'm guessing that the
monster is from the other world and that
you card can connect to the other world
with the warp oh so it is supernatural
yes explains your bed clue more stuff to
read you want to go ahead again oh [ __ ]
the hell
locked wards are failing the shadow
Becker
and it's cry disarmed twice I still -
shut up
Onan really oh where did he do it save
yourself he's a murderer evil
blooded killer hurry computing oh well
you read this and freak
this was is he getting out I can't do
anything
he wrote the same date that's the
oh [ __ ] so that's what he wanted to
forget